hello my name is Alejandro Ramirez a
grandmaster and I'm Grandmaster
Christian Carrillo and we're here to
demonstrate the differences between the
time controls that we use in chess
increment delay and the old school
analog system and the first one we're
going to see is the increment and
control alejandro
good luck this is one plus two so you'll
see my clock increasing every time I
make a move
go for it Christian as we will as we
already see I made let's say five to six
moves and I have more time than I
started off with this allows a smart
user to think when he needs to and still
have enough time for the rest of the
game let's go I think okay actually
canvas well what am i doing
now it's a good time to think positions
complicated and I even have more time
than I started with
we're go ahead and take this not in a
big rush and I think that this first
sacrifice along with this you know
that's fine I feel I should punish you
somehow no development see how to do
that I still have more time than what I
started off with which is very common in
a bully game with increment to easy been
missing something nope
Wow that is a very brave move you know
if you actually look at that all right
let's see have to checkmate this guy
believe in anything you're doing me
neither but but my time and I was
running low so I have to play fast now I
can accumulate a little bit of time so
I'm not too scared
I really should hurry okay let's make
some space ah you want to come here with
your horsey without idea yeah yeah
without increment I wouldn't allow
myself to fall down on time so much but
I know I can accumulate some so too
scared oh I'm sorry
material but compensation
well can't castle solid compensation now
you got your phone back
yep and I'm catching up on time again
because of the increment
last step in this side
like this
everything else to recapture this go
forward for
all right I'm messing this up a little
bit back
make some quick moves paint some time
this is very complicated exploit much
immature
let's go it mm-hmm I don't like what's
happening here but I do all right let's
go check is fine should push pawns oh
and I flagged here so even though I had
increment is still very dangerous
because it's only 2 seconds so she's
still complicated but I flag so I lost
the game now that being said I kind of
allowed myself to be too low on time I
didn't play fast enough if I wanted to I
could have played a lot faster increment
my time but I didn't so I kind of failed
in that game we have to remember at the
beginning of each game during the
championship showdown they would have 5
minutes each so much more time than what
we started off with right we're just
explaining here the differences between
increment and delay what that's next and
the old type control so let's try the
lie all right we're here with delay and
the difference you'll see we can't
actually act the time to our clock
they're still going to be a two second
pause before our time actually starts
but we can't actually accumulate any
time so you'll see there's actually a
much much faster time control than
increment so good luck
so unlike the last game we're actually
playing relatively quickly but our times
not passing from one minute it's not
going down either because we're making
our moves within the two seconds so here
I'm gonna let my time run a little bit
two seconds three and it starts running
so here we're playing a lot faster even
if we don't know the theory because time
is gonna go way way down and we don't
have any time anyway to recuperate it
choices choices this took too long with
that move again it's not increment this
is why I quit playing 1.e4 yeah I never
never knew the theory the theory was
always something very evasive very
slight very slight
I am a greedy man I think that's
actually the correct approach I'm a very
greedy man yeah this is not going well
and I have no time to recover I have to
play faster this is going very badly for
me but I have tricks and with this back
control there's always some tricks
there's always a chance
I get late for trips let's go of course
as I was expecting
alright let's give a check first oh this
is not good for me now the tricks are
coming this is not good for me
soldering coordination that's a sad
story that's that story indeed I go with
check here
sad story indeed now here I have enough
time to meet him which is good
congratulations thank you so now we're
gonna see the type of time control that
they were going to use at the champions
showdown coming up here in st. Louis
different from the delay or the
increment this is actually just a sudden
death type of time control in which no
time can be delayed or added by far the
most exciting type in my opinion for a
lot of people that's the most exciting
type some people see it as not real
chess because of some of the craziness
that ensures in the time scrambles but
for some it just makes it all that more
much more attractive so we're gonna be
playing fewer one minute chess and that
means no increment no delay now this is
too fast and because that there's
actually no time to talk you don't want
to lose time okay that's degree blank
good chess is important and of course
the showdown is gonna see a slower time
control than this but time is pretty
much all there is to it say that I don't
like my position Wow
sacrificing this chicks changed I don't
have time to think okay let's get rid of
this Bishop oh this looks really bad oh
I'm gonna get the killed should have
thought more about this here he goes
Queen c3 and I'm just lost all right how
do I get out of this I don't think you
do it again I played too fast and I'm
gonna suffer the consequences they
didn't use my tank properly nope that's
it and that's what happens games go this
fast you need to manage your time
correctly sometimes strategy is
extremely important you have to think at
the right moment and you cannot
overthink when the time is not right
right so obviously your position on the
board as you can see is extremely
important we're gonna be seeing players
blitz out moves extremely quickly
because it doesn't
matter sometimes if you have extra
material you don't have the time to
prove it it's not gonna be enough
I remember one tournament I played in
Dallas maybe a few years ago and I
played against one of my good friends
and it was a crazy time scramble and I
was going to get made it in the next
five moves but he lost some time I was
simply just giving all my pieces away
and just trying to make moves fast so I
think we're going to see some very very
explosive chests in the upcoming
shoulder